le premier ministre qui s'est exprimé ce
matin sur les ondes de france info
nous sommes dans une deuxième vague
force at il affirmé alors où en est on
très concrètement de la situation
sanitaire l'exécutif tient-t-il le bon
cap
on le décrypte tout de suite avec nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec stéphane caillet médecins
infectiologues ou chru de strasbourg
bonsoir à vos côtés stéphane rozès
politologue président de cap conseils
analyses et perspectives enseignant à
hec et sciences pour bonsoir alors je le
disais à l'instant nous sommes dans une
deuxième vague forte a dit jean castex
alors cette fois vous confirmez stéphane
caillet vous la voyez cette deuxième
vague à strasbourg je ne confirme pas je
conteste cette notion pour moi il n'y a
pas de deuxième vague forte
il ya une petite reprise il ya une
petite vague et quand on regarde les
courbes alors le problème que l'on a
actuellement et c'est que la politique
de communication et de décisions du
gouvernement repose essentiellement sur
une politique de pratique intensive de
test je dis bien de détection de traces
darren virale de détection de traces d'
iron virale on sait très bien que ces
tests ont de nombreux faux positif parce
que l'amplification c'est la méthode de
détection du génome viral de certaines
parties du génome viral l'amplification
est intense elle est très poussé de
façon à ce qu'il y ait un minimum de
faux négatifs et résultat on a beaucoup
de faux positifs et le fait d'avoir sur
sa muqueuses rhinopharyngées des traces
d' iron virales ne signifie pas que l'on
est ipso facto que l'on soit ipso facto
contagieux et que l'on soit ipso facto
infecté c'est à dire en cours de maladie
c'est une ça me paraît extrêmement
important
les on parle d'épidémie une épidémie
c'est un ensemble de cas d'infections
qui se répandent qui se multiplient dans
une population mais on parle de cas
d'infection henry si on parle de portage
de traces d' iron virale si je regarde
les indicateurs de morbidité
c'est-à-dire de deux maladies qui nous
sont mis à disposition tous les jours
sur le site de géo de santé publique
france on voit très bien qu'il n'y a pas
de deuxième vague sur le plan de la
mobilité c'est-à-dire de la maladie il y
a une petite progression d'ailleurs elle
commence à stagner depuis quelque temps
nous en sommes à peu près entre le 6e et
le 7e de la situation lorsqu'elle était
critique
fin mars début avril j'aurais aimé
pouvoir
donc nous ne sommes pas finalement même
stade que celui de mars avril dernier ce
que vous nous dit ce soir tout mais
absolument pas et nous nous sommes
rentrés le septième est le sixième de la
situation morbide du mois d'avril le pic
était au 1er avril
alors en tout cas en tout cas stéphane
rozès le président de la république dans
ce contexte de deuxième vague annoncée
par le premier ministre doit s'exprimer
mercredi deux jours avant les vacances
scolaires donc selon vous comment le
président de la république doit t'il
appréhender cette prise d pas de parole
est-ce que emmanuel macron est en mesure
de convaincre les citoyens français
aujourd'hui
d'abord reconnaissons qu'il ya une au
fond de nécessité pourquoi parce que on
comprend bien qu'à l'intérieur du corps
médical et des scientifiques ya un
désaccord quant à la nature de ce que
nous vivons par rapport à la copie de
10,9 et dans un pays comme la france
c'est aux politiques d'abord de dire le
cours des choses d'anticiper et de
réparer
et donc l'exigence à l'égard du
président c'est au fond de statuer les
français découvrent que contrairement à
ce qu'ils pensent les scientifiques ont
évidemment des certitudes mais en
matière de recherche
ils peuvent diverger entre eux il s'est
même la dispute scientifique qui fait
que l'on progresse
et donc dans le climat d'inquiétudes
sanitaires mais aussi économique et
social spontanément on se tourne vers le
politique pour dire le cours des choses
et de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
il priait un peu à harbour pourquoi
parce que quand il nomme le premier
ministre
castex il pense que ça va lui permettre
de prendre un peu de distance
or le profil du premier ministre ce
texte c'est un profil d'amortisseur de
crise économique et sociale
or l'arrivée à nouveau de la crise
pandémique au dessus de l'inquiétude
économique et social demanderait un
premier ministre de combat c'est pas
exactement le profil de chant qu'un
steak c'est plutôt un homme de dialogue
de territoire d'amodiation et donc ça
oblige le président de la république à
monter en première ligne mercredi sans
doute annoncer des mauvaises nouvelles
soient déconfinement partiel soit des
couvre feux mais ça correspond bien au
fond à la psychologie du pays qui est de
focaliser sur le politique et c'est là
où je retrouve le propos antérieurs du
docteur c'est à dire que au fond comme
le politique dans un premier temps avait
sous-estimé la crise il ya une pression
politique sur le politique au risque de
surestimer objectivement ce que nous
vivons par rapport aux creux vide
nonobstant des sujets de fond
auquel l'ancien patron d'un institut de
sondage et sensible qui est la question
du réel des indicateurs et de leur
interprétation
c'est à dire je tue évidemment pas du
tout un spécialiste de ces questions là
je prendrai garde de rentrer dans le
débat mais on comprend que les tests ont
focalisé l'attention sur certaines
caractéristiques de la nature de la
pandémie en oubliant peut-être ou en
relativisant le fait que certes il ya
plus de circulation mais au fond la
nocivité du virus peut varier
ou bien que des personnes arrivant à
l'hôpital ont certes une somme certes
contaminés mais aussi peuvent aussi être
à l'hôpital pour d'autres raisons
donc il ya des raisons aa au sentiment
de flou d'inquiétude et d'impréparation
du politique il ya des raisons
directement politique objective et puis
il ya aussi des relations des raisons
cognitives de bonne analyse de
l'évolution de la pandémie quand les
outils de mesure ont changé quand on
regarde certains teams d'indicateurs que
pas d'autre alors des raisons politiques
vous devinez pour jean castex
il y à il ya d'autres raisons il s'est
exprimé ce matin sur le comportement des
français ont regardé ont réagi les
français ont collectivement considéré
que c'était fini que c'était derrière
nous je n'ai cessé tout l'été d'appeler
à la vigilance
stéphane gaillard selon le premier
ministre les français ont considéré un
peu trop invite que ce virus avait
disparu alors est ce que c'est la faute
des français finalement si la situation
sanitaire on est là aujourd'hui je sais
tu es fan day effectivement les français
ont sans doute cru en juillet en août
que la situation épidémique était était
terminée en vérité le virus circule le
virus circule mais il circule à bas
bruit
il circule de façon douce c'est ce que
j'appelle à la transmission 12 et la
vérité et que de toute façon pour que
cette épidémie puisse prendre fin il
faut que la population s'immunise petit
à petit étant donné qu' il n'y aura pas
de vaccins dans l'immédiat contrairement
à ce qu'on nous dit est souvent parce
que c'est une affaire complexe
or on sait maintenant ça a été affirmée
s'étaient vérifiées
il faut pas dire que leslie
scientifiques ont des certitudes non ça
ce n'est pas vrai mais il ya quelques
notions qui semble vraiment acquise et
sur lesquels on peut tabler et ça cette
notion de maladies immunisante c'est
quelque chose qui était confirmée encore
récemment par bruno lina qui est un quai
virologue au chu de lyon et qui est un
des spécialistes du coronavirus et il a
bien affirmé que cette maladie était
immunisante c'est à dire que alors si ce
n'est jamais du 100% en en médecine et
en biologie
mais l'immense majorité des personnes
qui ont fait la maladie sont immunisés
alors avec des anticorps ou avec une
immunité à médiation cellulaire mais
sont immunisés et donc ne devrait pas
refaire cette maladie ce qui amène ada a
considéré que la fin de l'épidémie sera
apportée par une immunisation collective
et qu'elle commence à être suffisante à
partir de 60 70 % de la population
alors certains donnent des taux
d'immunisation actuelle à dire vrai on
n'en sait rien du tout on n'en sait rien
du tout mais ce que l'on constate c'est
que il ya effectivement une circulation
intense du virus
j'en veux pour preuve tous ces tests arn
qui sont positifs
alors que sur le plan de la maladie eh
bien les hôpitaux ne sont pas beaucoup
rempli le nombre de nouvelles
hospitalisations quotidienne pour
coville 19 est faible actuellement le
nombre de nouvelles admissions en
réanimation pour kobe 19 est faible donc
il y à une circulation du virus
oui c'est vrai mais il y a peu de
malades est beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins que ce que la situation à laquelle
on était confronté en mars et en avril
et donc je suis de ceux qui considèrent
qu'il faut que le virus circule mais il
doit circuler de façon douce de façon
feutrée filtrer grâce au port du masque
grâce à tout un ensemble de mesures de
prévention mais je répète ce que j'ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises on est
dans l'excès on est dans l'excès le port
du masque à l'extérieur n'a pas n'a pas
grand sens
et c'est qu'elle sait quelque chose
qu'on impose aux gens qui nuit à la
qualité de vie et ça ce ça ne se
justifiait pas à l'extérieur sauf
lorsqu'il ya une concentration de
personnes et mobile ça ne se justifie
pas sur le plan de la prévention
alors effectivement la question du port
du masque on en débat souvent en tout
cas parmi les annonces du jour il y a eu
celle d'une nouvelle de là dans une
nouvelle version de l'application stop
coville pour le 22 octobre l'application
ans il de juin dernier elle n'avait pas
rencontré le succès escompté par le
gouvernement on regarde les explications
de jean marc aussi comme l'on pouvait
s'y attendre l'application stock co vide
et n'a jusqu'à présent pas été
particulièrement efficace l'appli aurait
été téléchargé seulement 2,6 millions de
fois depuis son lancement il y a quatre
mois soit par moins de 4% des français
un chiffre dérisoire si on le compare
aux applications équivalentes chez nos
voisins 16 millions de téléchargements
pour nhs coville 19 au royaume uni 18
millions pour corona web apps en
allemagne 8 3 millions pour immouni en
italie et même plus de 2.4 millions de
téléchargements pour swiss qu'ovide soit
presque autant qu'en france alors que
nos voisins helvètes sont huit fois
moins nombreux cela dit les difficile
d'accabler les français quand même leur
premier ministre ne s'est pas plié à
l'exercice
le 24 septembre jean castex avait
lui-même admis ne pas avoir téléchargé
l'application et ces mêmes trompés de
nom ce lundi au micro de france info
avez vous téléchargez l'application
stable que vite sur votre téléphone
non non par non à charge et là je ne
l'ait pas fait
mais pourquoi mais vous pousser les
français à le faire ne l'avais pas fait
je n'ai pas téléchargé tecau vite alors
maintenant je vous annonce en réalité
téléco vide
indépendamment de ma propre personne n'a
pas eu les effets escomptés
de toute façon les chiffres de stocks
que vide n'était pas bon même avant ces
révélations
en cause notamment le caractère du
fameux gaulois réfractaires très
certainement ou peut être aussi la
méfiance vis-à-vis d'un gouvernement
très critiqué pour sa gestion de la
crise sanitaire notamment l'épisode des
masques et puis face à une application
lancée par le gouvernement les français
on craint pour leurs données
personnelles des craintes pas totalement
injustifié puisque très vite après son
lancement l'application a été accusé
d'être plus indiscrètes qu'annoncé mais
ne culpabilisons pas même les
populations ayant téléchargé massivement
l'application sont encore loin du compte
selon une étude de l'université
britannique d'oxford
un tel outil devrait être utilisée par
60% de la population pour une efficacité
maximum et même une fois ce seuil
atteint il faut que l'application
remplissent bien sa fonction
et c'est là que le bât blesse car même
en admettant que tous les français et
télécharger ce top cow vide pour qu'un
utilisateur ayant croisé une personne
malade soit averti par l'application
encore faut-il que les deux téléphones
étaient allumés au moment du contact que
l'application était active sur les deux
smartphones tout comme le bluetooth que
le bluetooth et bien détecté l'autre
téléphone
que la personne malade est bien fait un
test pcr et que ce test ne soit pas un
faux négatifs et que la personne malade
ce soit bien déclarer comme telles dans
l'application et c'est donc aussi pour
cela que ce top cow vide a été aussi peu
efficaces seulement 472 notification à
deux potentiels qu'à contacter au cours
de la semaine passée alors que près de
8000 personnes se sont déclarées malades
via leur smartphone un maigre bilan qui
s'observe également chez nombre de nos
voisins
alors stop vide n'a pas coûté une
fortune à l'état français seulement cent
mille euros par mois un budget mensuel
qui devrait doubler avec la prochaine
mouture de l'application alors sera t
elle efficace cette fois ci est bien
comme dit presque le dicton qui survivra
verra alors stéphane rozès les français
ont boudé un la première version de ce
top cow vides comment comprenez vous que
le gouvernement finalement persiste dans
cette voie
je crois qu'il faut bien comprendre
quelque chose j'ai travaillé sur ces
questions de rapport des français à
l'intelligence artificielle au numérique
au data à leur mutualisation
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les promoteurs de ce type d'application
insiste beaucoup et c'est compréhensible
sur le comment ça fonctionne et
d'ailleurs votre journaliste vient de le
faire dire comment ça fonctionne
est-ce que c'est efficace ou pas or dans
l'imaginaire français parce que pour
nous le progrès doit précéder
l'innovation la vraie question c'est
pourquoi c'est pourquoi et non pas
comment et quelle est la destination
politique collective de cette
application est donc nonobstant les
questions techniques que votre
journaliste a rappelé sur la première
application de stock covin ya un
problème réel de communication
du gouvernement sur ce type de
plateforme d'outils qui doit être
présenté au public à l'envers de la
façon dont en général c'est fait puisque
les défis à la française sont des défis
du côté de l'offre du côté technique
donc il faut avoir les meilleures
applications en termes d'ingénieurs de
pensée de l'ingénieur numérique
or pour le citoyen c'est pas une sujet
faut d'abord dire pourquoi quelle est la
maîtrise du politique de ces questions
là qu'elle va être l'utilité l' avantage
du point de vue de l'intérêt général et
de l'intérêt sanitaires collectifs
stéphane gagné alors parmi les
nombreuses mesures on parlait du port du
masque tout à l'heure notamment à
l'extérieur vous n'était pas forcément
pour ça n'engage que vous beaucoup
estiment que c'est nécessaire en tout
cas cette application est ce que l es un
vrai bon moyen de lutter contre
l'épidémie est ce qu'il faut convaincre
les français à la télécharger en tant
que médecin qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que cette application part
d'une très bonne attention et sur le
plan mathématique sur le plan de la pure
logique épidémiologique
c'est intéressant mais en pratique ça ne
fonctionne pas bien et surtout en france
alors pourquoi les français n'y ont pas
adhéré mais parce que depuis le début de
l'épidémie en france donc fin février
début mars
il y a eu tout un ensemble de maladresse
de la part du pouvoir exécutif et tant
et si bien que une non seulement une
méfiance mais une réelle défiance s'est
instauré de la part de la population
vis-à-vis des autorités de santé et du
poids exécutif en général prenons
quelques exemples au début ça a été dit
mais je crois qu'il est toujours bon de
le répéter on a commencé à dire que le
masque ce n'était pas quelque chose de
très utiles et que l'on pouvait s'en
dispenser y compris et c'est grave dans
les établissements de santé
ensuite on s'est trompé sur la distance
de sécurité on a annoncé 1 m c'était une
erreur
la distance est de un mètre cinquante et
dans les pays anglophones c'est souvent
un mètre 82 m ça n'a jamais été un
maître mais il ya eu une erreur qui a
été commise par le ministère chargé de
la santé et bien sûr il n'a pas été
question ensuite de rectifier
officiellement cette erreur mais dans
tous les établissements de santé on sait
très bien qu'à 10 ans était de la mettre
50 etc etc on peut multiplier les
exemples
donc et cette méfiance et maintenant
cette défiance de la part de la
population vis-à-vis des autorités de
santé ne les incite pas du tout c'est
évident à s'équiper de cette application
d'autant plus que comme ça été dit on
n'a pas suffisamment expliqué comment
elle fonctionne et on n'a pas
suffisamment rassuré les gens puisqu'il
ya beaucoup de méfiance quant à
l'utilisation des données personnelles
et donc ça n'a pas été convaincant et
résultat très peu de français ont
téléchargé l'application et puis comme
ça a été dit aussi l été elle était un
peu peut-être trop ambitieuse alors que
dans nos pays et nos pays proches nos
pays frontaliers au contraire
l'application à à mieux fonctionner bien
en tout cas on verra à partir du 22
octobre
effectivement surveillera de près pour
voir si cette application est
téléchargée par un grand nombre de
français en tout cas un grand merci à
tous les deux pour nous avoir aidé à
décrypter cette situation sanitaire mais
rassis avoue stéphane caillet je
rappelle ce que vous êtes médecin
infectiologue au chru de strasbourg
merci à vous stéphane rozès politologue
président de cap conseils analyses et
perspectives enseignant à hec et
sciences-po